So here's the background.
We have a imaginary country.
that exports
Grains, like wheat and barley we call countries
like this that export.
So a coffee beans like essential food
items to other countries a bread basket.
Okay.
So when it comes to wheat, it's you know, Russia, Ukraine.
other countries in Eastern Europe many countries
depend on the Imports of these countries,
so
you may have heard the news right now that the price of
Bread has gone up and this is problematic in
many countries where bread?
is the main
food of consumption the price goes up and that just
drives the price of many things up. It's coincidence.
Now, this is the problem because this is the one I found in the
book, but I adapt it.
To make it, you know rather relevant to what we
know what we're hearing the news today. Anyway, we have this country that
exports great to other countries.
And they need to ship.
there there
they're great. So there is another there's a
state-owned manufacturer a government-owned company that produces
containers we call these container liners.
They look something like this.
so, you know you put these in the cargo like
they want to find in mirk, but these are you know meant to
keep
the grain dry
It's just for cargo, okay?
now they have
two types
two designs two models
one is the standard model.
And the other one is the premium. So what's
what how are they different?
Okay, and of course, we we didn't know the standard container
would C sub s and the premium one would see sub
pieces the C stands for container.
So the standard container can contain 100 kilograms
of barley and 100 kilograms of wheat.
Or as a premium one can hold 200 kilograms of
barley and 100 kilograms of wheat.
I am not an expert in agriculture, but
Apparently you can design containers this way. You can mix it together.
Now this company the state
owned manufacturer now, it doesn't matter if it's date on a private.
It's just
Then the numbers here and the variables are important for
us this company. This manufacturer has received a
quote.
to sell or provide
the government with containers
for the following
the manufacturer is supposed to produce continuous for 30 million
tons of Wheat and
40 million tons of barley. Now I've used
This notation because when it comes to
plotting it will become easier. So we're going to actually drop the units of
measurement.
So we will stick to 300 to 4000 not just for
context it. They export
in the millions in the millions of tons.
now
what we want what what this LP problem is about is
maximizing the profit margin for
the company.
What combination of containers can we use to maximize the
profit?
So they will earn 80 cents of the dollar.
if they sell
premium containers and 70 cents for
the standard container
Okay.
and
what we need to do first is Express the
objective function.
So basically we need to model the relationship between
how of how much they will make.
and
then maximize this function.
So this is the objective function.
Okay.
Let me copy this bit here.
There's a lot of information going on in here, right? So let's
break it down. I'll break it down. Okay, just
give you some background first.
So let me actually put these up here.
Because I don't want to these are not the same. This is a
different task. So this is the problem.
tasks
and then there's the lp tasks.
So the objective function is the following the
objective function is this
they will earn 80 cents.
For every premium container that they that they
sell to the government.
And 70 cents where we
stand a container.
That they sell.
So the objective function is a function of two
variables.
the number of Premium containers and the number of standard containers
not good for convenience.
We're going to swap.
C sub p and C Sub C with X and Y.
It's just notational convenience. So
we will let x equal to the premium the number
of Premium containers and Y equals
to the number of
standard containers
So this is the objective function now.
It is a function of two variables.
And this is the relationship.
Now we want to maximize this.
But we have constraints.
We have this constraints.
What are the constraints let's see.
The constraints are the following.
the first one
now these constraints say that then the
combination of containers you use the number of
continues use cannot exceed.
the amount that you are allocated
So for example in the for wheat, we
have 30 million tons.
So we need to I mean, yeah, so
we cannot exceed.
Whenever we when we solve for this equation, we plotted
we cannot exceed the quantity.
And of course the below what is for the barley?
These constraints will once we plotted and you
know solve for the roots the X and y's.
We will know up to what number of standard or to
what up to what number of Premium containers we can you know, we can
we can adjust.
So the tasks are this.
Given the objective function. So let's now
this is our new objective function the one that's f of
x
this is the objective function.
And these are the constraints.
tasks number one
We need to find the feasible region.
for the objective function
and then find the best point.
within that region
so we need to know what are the limitations of our parameters and
then within the within the
within the region
For a parameters. What is the most what is the point? I'll give us
maximum profit.
Okay, this is only two constraints.
But then we can generalize it for problems where
we have multiple constraints.